[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy esther herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy analizamos que está ocurriendo
con los precios de la energía porque
están subiendo porque europa se está
viendo tan afectada antes de pasar al
debate con nuestros invitar motors
repasamos la situación actual con los
precios del gas y de la electricidad en
europa y en el mundo
los precios del gas y de la electricidad
se encuentran en máximos históricos en
la unión europea han crecido en un año
casi un 500 por ciento las razones se
cuentan en una lista el invierno pasado
fue largo con una primavera muy fría y
luego un verano caluroso que provoca un
aumento de la demanda de la electricidad
por otra parte la falta de viento
tampoco ayudó a la generación de la
energía eólica otras razones son el
aumento de la demanda en china lo cual
provocó un incremento de los precios
todas estas circunstancias han hecho que
las reservas de la unión europea se
reduzcan de manera drástica muchos
países también apuntan a rusia como la
causante el país es uno de los
principales suministradores de gas al
bloqueo europeo pero a pesar del aumento
de la demanda no ha respondido tan
rápido como hasta ahora algunos estados
del este creen que es una maniobra de
moscú para presionar y se apruebe la
concesión del gasoducto nord stream 2
que bombear a gas directamente desde
rusia hasta alemania sin tener que pasar
por ucrania ante esta situación los
países europeos están divididos sobre
cómo actuar algunos como españa o
república checa- piden más medidas a
nivel europeo como la compra conjunta de
gas para reducir los precios de momento
el bloque europeo busca soluciones pero
bruselas ha lanzado la alerta de que
cada país debe tomar sus propias medidas
y para analizar lo que está ocurriendo
en el mercado energético en el debate de
europa hoy contamos con los otros
diputados jordi solé del grupo de los
verdes/alianza libre europea e izaskun
bilbao de renovar europa bienvenidos
jordi izaskun muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros me gustaría empezar primero
de todo con jordi hay varias razones que
explican el aumento de los precios de la
energía y justo llega en un momento
clave de la recuperación económica
existe alguna solución a corto plazo si
existen medidas que los gobiernos pueden
tomar y que de hecho algunos de ellos se
han tomado por ejemplo en la fiscalidad
o una cuestión muy importante que es
ayudar a aquellas familias y también
empresas normalmente pequeñas y medianas
que afrontan a esta situación con muchas
dificultades
concretamente la cuestión de la pobreza
energética por ejemplo en francia el
gobierno ha anunciado un cheque de 100
euros para las familias más vulnerables
por lo tanto sí que hay medidas a corto
plazo pero el problema no se soluciona
sólo con eso son medidas muy importantes
pero no son suficientes
quizás a estas medidas a corto plazo
algunas de ellas las ha propuesto la
comisión europea para hay una
consecuencia clara de todo esto que es
un aumento de la inflación a causa del
aumento de los precios de la energía
también esto significa menos poder
adquisitivo en los hogares se frenará la
recuperación económica bueno esperemos
que no y efectivamente no hay medidas a
corto plazo pero yo creo que la pandemia
nos ha enseñado mucho y es que tenemos
todos que tener claro que tenemos que
construir una unión europea de la
energía y esto significa que tal y como
aprendimos en la en la pandemia con los
temas de los productos farmacéuticos
los productos sanitarios las vacunas lo
que tenemos que ir es a construir una
compra de ese espacio una compra
mancomunidad
almacenamiento de energía
tenemos que ser autosuficientes
energéticamente como unión europea' y
esto va a llevar un tiempo se han dado
las medidas los primeros pasos y yo creo
que las medidas no pueden caer solamente
en manos de cada uno de los gobiernos
tienen que ser medidas a nivel europeo y
por lo tanto también tenemos que
permitir que esta transición que en este
momento tenemos hacia una energía verde
una energía más sostenible una energía
más social tenga que tener una
transición que sea ordenada y que no
repercuta ni en las familias ni en las
empresas cosa que está ocurriendo en
este momento justamente ahora comentabas
la cuestión de las renovables el
parlamento europeo ha dicho mucha
intuición de que quizás esta crisis
podría ser un momento para incidir más
en las renovables es el momento de
apostar más por las energías renovables
es posible que una ciudad por ejemplo
como madrid o bruselas pueda depender
sólo de las energías renovables es el
momento de apostar claramente
masivamente en favor de las energías
renovables y además será una obligación
recordemos el objetivo 2030 de 55 por
ciento de reducción de co2 y por lo
tanto también un objetivo de un
porcentaje importante de renovables por
lo tanto tiene que haber una la
inversión y un apoyo político al
desplegar renovables
no sé si ahora mismo sería posible en el
corto plazo digamos que grandes ciudades
sólo puedan abastecerse de energías
renovables pero está claro que este debe
ser el objetivo que no debe ser un
objetivo
muchísimo a largo plazo sino aún digamos
a una década vista y que hay que
invertir en tecnología en investigación
en desarrollo en innovación para que
esto sea posible y las renovables lo que
nos permiten es acercar la generación de
electricidad al consumo y además además
hacerlo de una forma descentralizada y
distribuida y aquí lo local a la
dimensión local coge una importancia muy
muy muy relevante y es por eso que a
todo lo que se pueda hacer a nivel de
municipios de ciudades
de aglomeraciones metropolitanas va a
ser absolutamente relevante para
conseguir estos objetivos
2030 intermedios y 2050 ahora nos hemos
dado cuenta que somos mucho más
dependientes de rusia de lo que a la
unión europea le gustaría prometió el
presidente de rusia que bombearía más
algas a la unión europea está utilizando
este país como una medida de presión la
cuestión del gas bueno no es algo que
voy a afirmar yo en la última
comparecencia de la comisaria de
industria ella lo que afirmó fue ante un
cuestionamiento de uno de los diputados
que rusia estaba cumpliendo con sus
compromisos por lo tanto parece que no
estamos en una situación en la que rusia
esté utilizando este momento digamos
entre comillas de vulnerabilidad europea
para jugar con su gas es verdad que
después de la pandemia ha habido un
consumo enorme del gas y de la energía
porque creo que hemos salido todos en
tromba en todos los países sobre todo en
todo el sudeste asiático y esto ha
tenido unas consecuencias pero en el
caso de rusia
la comisaria dijo que no yo comparto con
jordi lo que dice que las medidas tienen
que ser a nivel local y hay que
distinguir dos cosas para conseguir los
objetivos globales desde los municipios
y estamos bien en muy buenas prácticas
por lo menos en nuestro entorno tanto
jordi en cataluña como yo en el país
vasco' de intervenciones locales para
conseguir los objetivos pero yo creo que
aquí se han mezclado varias cosas y por
eso estamos en esta gran burbuja por una
parte de los objetivos que ya nos
marcamos del acuerdo de parís porque
esto no era sostenible y evitar el
calentamiento global y por otra parte
los efectos de la pandemia entonces
bueno es la coctelera perfecta para
decir tenemos que transformarnos pero yo
quiero hacer mucho hincapié en que esto
tiene que ser ordenado podemos hablar de
energías renovables podemos hablar de
buenas prácticas necesitamos no
solamente inversión necesitamos una
transición ordenada porque si decimos no
al carbón quienes estén utilizando el
carbón tienen que tener las alternativas
y en esto tenemos que tener la
colaboración de todos y tiene que ver
soluciones por lo tanto tenemos todavía
mucha tarea que hacer los objetivos
parece que están claros y yo creo que
tenemos que avanzar sí o sí primero para
cumplir los objetivos del cambio
climático y en segundo lugar para tener
una energía suficiente que nos haga como
decía antes autosuficientes y por lo
tanto en esto tenemos que contar con una
gobernanza diferente a la que hemos
tenido hasta ahora antes estamos
comentando la cuestión de las propuestas
que ha hecho la comisión europea sobre
todo a corto plazo pero qué pasa a medio
plazo por ejemplo el gobierno español de
pérez antes está pidiendo una compra
conjunta de gas son soluciones porque la
comisión europea ha dicho que lo va a
analizar pero a sus tiempos si a mí me
parece que por ejemplo la compra
conjunta de gas o la creación de nuevas
reservas estratégicas para para el gas
son medidas que pueden ayudar
a amortiguar los efectos de esta de esta
subida de los precios pero creo que
también hay que plantear un cambio en el
modelo de fijación de los precios en el
mercado mayorista de la electricidad
porque lo que ocurre ahora es que la
energía más cara que entra en la
formación del precio es la que fija el
precio normalmente son energías
o sistemas de generación de electricidad
que utilizan energías fósiles
por lo tanto contaminantes y nos vemos
con la paradoja de que a las energías
renovables que tienen un coste menor de
producción no son las que acaban fijando
el precio y esto permitiría un ahorro
clarísimo por lo tanto yo creo que sí
que hay que estudiar el funcionamiento
actual del mercado de la electricidad de
hecho el consejo europeo el último que
se celebró en octubre dio la instrucción
de alguna manera a la comisión europea
de hacer este análisis y a partir de
aquí creo que sí que habría que hacer y
propuestas para reformar al menos el
sistema de fijación de precios para
favorecer a aquellas tecnologías que
sean limpias las renovables y en este
sentido la propuesta del gobierno
español me parece interesante y a tener
en cuenta
quizás
eres de una zona donde hay mucha
industria a muchas empresas químicas
también siderúrgicas algunas empresas
pueden a cerrar a causa de los aumentos
de la electricidad que consecuente qué
consecuencias puede haber ante esto lo
realmente
la situación es complicada y es verdad
que el incremento del precio de la
energía
afecta más a las zonas industriales como
es nuestra región como es euskadi
y algo que afectó mucho más
recientemente fue un decreto que quiso
aprobar el gobierno español donde
efectivamente se penalizaba precisamente
por la fijación de los precios las
empresas que tenían
consumo como son las industriales no un
consumo mucho más elevado que otro tipo
de industrial afortunadamente gracias a
la presión que mi grupo parlamentario
hizo en el congreso se corrigió aquello
y las empresas han podido continuar con
su actividad pero sí es verdad que el
precio está condicionando no tanto el
paro que si lo tuvo al inicio de ese
decreto sino el elevado precio que
pueden tener los productos y estas son
las consecuencias que al principio
comentabas que podrían tener pues todos
los productos y la inflación y las
consecuencias que esto podría tener en
el entorno incluso de las propias
familias no yo creo que bueno pues este
tipo de medidas hay que analizarlas bien
no cabe poner en un papel en las cosas
las realidades son muy diferentes zonas
industriales zonas no industriales zonas
con un consumo intensivo de ésta y por
lo tanto lo que cabe aquí como digo es
que hagamos una transición ordenada que
esto no dependa solamente de lo que
decide a cada uno de los países que
tengamos las conexiones energéticas de
un suministro a nivel europeo y yo creo
que estamos dando los pasos y
evidentemente sí creo que en la
definición a la hora de establecer los
precios de la luz no puede ser que
una electricidad que proceda de algo
fósil y una renovable puedo ante el
mismo precio por lo tanto hay que seguir
apostando por estas renovables y por
esta energía más social y más sostenible
pues tenemos que dejarlo aquí muchas
gracias a jordi y estás con muchísimas
gracias por vuestras aportaciones
nosotros les esperamos en el próximo
programa de europa hoy gracias por ver
france24 en español
[Música]